on est tous pour ou contre le nucléaire
pour contre les nanosciences pour ou
contre les ogm mais qui vante renault
est capable de dire ce qu'on est
vraiment dans un réacteur nucléaire
ce qu'est une réaction de fission
comment ça fonctionne
qu'implique galles mc2 qu'est ce que
c'est qu'une cellule souche un ogm
personnes
le trac répit d'arista nos savants pour
dire que souvent on parle avec assurance
de choses que nous ne connaissons pas et
ses dérivés d'une locution latine qui
est dessus thorn et supra crépy dame qui
veut dire en gros que le cordonnier ne
doit pas parler au delà de la chaussure
moi j'ai noté à cette tendance là au
tout début de l'épidémie
je rentrais du chili et en arrivant en
france alors que le confinement avaient
commencé depuis quelques jours je voyais
des tweets écrit par des personnalités
politiques parfois de très haut rang qui
commençait par je ne suis pas médecin
mais je pense et c est après cette
déclaration renette d'incompétence
s'ensuivait des injonctions sur ce qu'il
fallait faire ou penser à propos de tel
ou tel traitement
au tout début mais ça n'avait donné
qu'on puisse avoir autant d'assurance
alors même qu'on vient de déclarer cons
et des incompétents j'ai remarqué la
vendée qui j'ai un peu la question que
c'était une tendance assez naturel que
de réalité étudié par des psychologues
américains la fin du xxème siècle
s'appelle dominé krueger qui allez
remarquer que pour se rend compte qu'on
est incompétent bas il faut être
compétent au début quand on découvre un
nouveau champ eh bien on se sont
spontanément compétents par exemple moi
je connais rien au football mais si on
me demandait d'être sélectionneur de
l'équipe de france de football
spontanément je dirais pourquoi pas ça a
l'air simple on s'assoit sur un banc ont
fait des gestes on crie un peu et ça
doit être suffisant pour que l'équipe
gagne et puis en regardant les choses un
peu plus près on s'aperçoit que c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué nous sommes tous
appelés à être des teams de cet ultra
crépy de réalisme quand vous conversez
au café avec vos amis vous dites des
choses qui vont au delà de vos
compétences
c'est tout à fait naturel dans la
convention simplement il faut en avoir
conscience
et quand on a une parole publique qui
peut avoir des effets politiques
importants il faut être prudent
l'idée c'est pas du tout dire que chacun
est contraint dans sa liberté a laissé
la parole aux experts
en fait mon démon cratie n'importe qui a
le droit de poser une question aux
experts de les interpeller de les
interroger
mais c'est parce qu'ils aient fait la
saison donne son avis sans savoir
[Musique]
nous avons tendance à écouter ceux qui
parlent de tout comme si nous rassurait
comme si les gens qui ont des formes de
certitudes une forme d'arrogance aussi
nous assurer dans une période
d'incertitude dans les mêmes canaux de
communication circuit aujourd'hui des
connaissances scientifiques ou autres
des informations des commentaires des
opinions décès qui use et le fait que
toutes ces choses circulent dans les
mêmes canaux c'est que leur statut
respectif qui sont pourtant très
différents se contaminent je me rends
compte que les gens qui sont modérés qui
sont prudents qu'ils sont les deux
autres centristes
pour ce qui est des questions relatives
à la vérité parle beaucoup moins que les
gens qui sont extrémistes dans ce
domaine c'est un peu comme aux
politiques les gens qui sont extrêmes
parle plus que les gens qui font partie
de ce qu'on appelle la majorité
silencieuse et moi je pense que notre
démocratie pour garde gardé de sa
vivacité a besoin que les gens modérés
s'engage passionnément
l'idée même de démocratie a à voir avec
le fait qu'on puisse argumenté ils sont
donnés le temps sont simplement
s'imposer s'opposer pardon avec des
arguments à ces primaires qui donne
l'impression que ce sont des arguments
d'autorité qui se combattent et non pas
des analyses